Saviez-vous que la consommation de fromage
varie de la même manière que le nombre de
personnes qui meurent emmêlées dans leur
draps?
Saviez-vous que le nombre de fautes à une
dictée par des élèves âgés de 6 à 12
ans varie en même temps que leur pointure?
Manger du fromage avant d’aller au lit est-il
donc dangereux?
Et faut-il avoir de grands pieds pour être
bon en orthographe?
Ces relations entre des variables sont des
corrélations.
Une corrélation est l’évolution simultanée
de deux variables dans le même sens ou dans
un sens inverse.
Toutefois, il ne faut pas confondre corrélation
et causalité.
Les deux variables ne sont pas forcément
liées directement.
Une troisième variable peut être la cause
des deux autres.
L’âge est à la fois la cause de la pointure
des élèves mais aussi du nombre de fautes
à une dictée.
Il n’y a donc aucun lien de causalité directe
entre la pointure et la dictée, il s’agit
juste d’une corrélation qui dans certains
cas sera due au seul hasard.
Alors oserez-vous encore manger du fromage
avant d’aller au lit?